we're now going to look at some simple
but reasonably practical applications of
least squares
we're going to see a lot more before the
course is over but just to give you some
very simple ones
obviously these are simplified and you
can be you can be much more
sophisticated in these
these applications it's just to give you
a flavor
okay so the first one is concerns
advertising
purchases okay so the way that works is
we have
m demographics groups we want to
advertise too so here's one for example
uh 18 to 22 year old you know college
students there's one demographic here's
another one
you know women uh you know 35 to 40
years old there's another demographic
but you have a bunch of these
and i think there are standards for
these different demographic groups okay
them might be tens could be hundreds i
don't know
whatever doesn't depends all right so
each of those groups you want to
advertise to
and what i do is i have a target v
desired v superscript des which is for
desired
um that's a a an m vector of target
views or an impression now a viewer an
impression and by the way you don't need
to know this the class is not about
advertising obviously so it's just an
example so don't worry
if you don't if you don't know what i'm
in fact it's not like i know that much
about this either so fine
um so a viewer impression as def is
defined
as a moment when a
person in in the target group sees an ad
or receives an offer or anything like
that i mean it could be on a website it
could be
it could be also it could be anything
it's it covers a lot of things
so that's called a view or impression
okay and so what this is is you've got a
vector here
of the target views or impressions in
other words you'd say
i want 18 to 20 year old college
students i would like to
deliver 50 000 impressions to them
right in my advertising campaign okay
so um i have an n vector s
and that that's going to give me uh it's
going to give me
my spending in dollars on n
advertising channels okay now
an advertising channel is uh you know
it's
it's just what it sounds like it's
something where you
pay them and uh they
they serve impressions right so
sometimes it's a publisher
it could be uh on a search engine could
be all sorts of stuff
could even be traditional stuff like you
know magazine ads or something i mean it
could be right
so those are uh those are those those
are so called advertising channels
okay and then what you have is a matrix
m by n
r and it's called the reach matrix
and what it does is it's going to tell
you for each of your channels
how many uh you know for let's say a
dollar that you spend
on each channel it tells you actually
how many impressions you get in your m
demographics groups okay so let's see
um rij is the number of views
per dollar spent you know maybe in let's
say a thousand views per dollar i don't
know whatever so
a view costs you uh whatever that is a
ten hundredth of a cent
or yeah tenth of a cent sorry there you
go okay
so it's it's how many for if you spend a
dollar in that channel
you're gonna get a thousand views right
so if you spend 100 bucks you get
whatever that's hundred thousand
okay that's so rij is the number of
views per dollar spent
and so that's an interesting matrix
right we can take a look at it it
you know looks like this and as i would
recommend you do
always when we get into applications go
slow sit down
and ask yourself you should always ask
yourself the following
what does a row of that matrix mean and
what does a column
so let's answer that question so what
does
the third row of this matrix mean
well it's super it's a row vector its
width is n n is the number
of advertising channels i have so
this is the third demographic group
let's suppose it's 18 to 22 year old
college students
then what this says is it will tell me
for all of my channels
uh every time i spend a dollar on that
advertising channel it tells you how
many people in each
in this group are gonna are actually
gonna get an impress
get get an impression okay so uh
i could ask you this how would i find if
i
only wanted to target 18 to 22 year old
college students right if that's all i
ever wanted to do
then it's really simple i would scan
across this row and i would find the
largest entry
because that is the one that is most
efficient for one dollar i will get the
most 18 to 22 year olds
okay so that would not be for example
advertising in like aarp or something
like that that's
american association of retired persons
that would be a very bad choice
and presumably there's a shockingly
small number there meaning that for
every dollar you
you spend advertising with them guess
what you're not hitting
college students okay so all right
um let's think about let's think about
let's say the fourth column
in this matrix that's also super
interesting um
so the fourth column is associated with
the fourth um
advertising channel right something like
that i don't know what it is
um so that that's the fourth column
and what it does is it gives me it tells
me this it says that when i spend a
dollar
um on the fourth on on the fourth
advertising channel
um if i read down this vector it tells
me
how many people in each demographic
group i hit
that's what it is right so you can ask
things like this
hey for advertising channel number four
um which group gets the most impressions
and we can look it up and find out who
it is right
uh you just scan down here and you say
oh it's demographic group number 22 and
then you'd have to look up what
demographic group 22 is
right so that's the idea okay so and by
the way i recommend doing this like
always right because after a while we
kind of get you know those matrices
flying around but some of them are going
to be huge and
it's it's very important you sit down
and actually try to understand what each
of these
what they mean okay all right so this is
the matrix
r now if i multiply
r times s the reach matrix times the
spending vector
then i get a vector which is v
and v is actually the views i get so if
i say i'm gonna spend a dollar
you know uh on these magazine ads and
i'm gonna spend
you know two dollars with google with
these search words and i'm going to do
that and blah blah and i go on and on
okay
then what's going to happen is that's s
and then i multiply by r and matrix
vector multiplication here
converts the amount you spend on each of
the channels
into the number of impressions you get
in every in every one of the demographic
groups
okay so that's the idea and what we
would like
is we would like uh v
to be some target one right because some
some people in the analytics department
said okay for our product
here here are the people who are going
to buy our product it's these people
please target them okay okay
um so this is the idea uh
and we can do this we can look at when
you choose an s
here r s or v desired minus r s
divided by squared m because this has a
length of m
a a dimension of m that is the rms
deviation from the desired views
okay and we could use least squares
spending
uh so that would be we simply
we get as close as we can um oh i'm
assuming here that the reach matrix is
tall
and has linearly independent columns um
actually it's super
interesting to see what it means for um
for entry for if that were false right
or in simple cases right like
what it would it'd actually be kind of
interesting if if this
has dependent columns r it means that
one column is a linear combination of
the others
that's interesting because what that
means is that you don't need that
advertising channel
because you can replicate it
with a linear combination of other
channels so
so it all kind of makes sense even the
linear independence here makes sense
okay now we'll use least squares
spending
and that says that says decide how much
money to spend in each channel
to get as close as possible as measured
by the norm or norm squared or rms value
uh to this target uh to this target
uh views or impressions right and so
that's going to be this thing
now at this point i do have to admit
something to you just out of honesty
um that uh when you do this there's no
reason to believe that
s hat is going to be have positive
entries and that's going to be very
awkward because it's going to say
uh you should go let's say you're trying
to hit college students it's going to
say you know what
not only should you not spend on you
know aarp magazine
you should actually spend a negative
amount now that doesn't make any sense
and you're not allowed to do that
so uh however i'm just admitting that
i can also tell you this that if you
fast forward a couple of classes
you will find out that you can actually
ensure
that the s's are uh are non-negative
so it's not a problem it's just not
something that's in scope
of this course and this book okay so
that's it
um let's look at an example i mean it's
very baby example just to
just to give you a rough idea so i have
10 demographic groups and i have three
advertising channels
um my target views vector is this
is i want to hit um let's say
a thousand a thousand a thousand now i
believe that the
views was in thousands of views so
basically i have three i have ten
demographic groups and i would like a
million people in each group
to see my ad or whatever it is okay so
that's the
that that's the idea and that's it
doesn't it didn't have to be but it's a
simple way to do it so we do this
now when you actually work out what is r
hat uh our dagger times times v desired
you get this and it says that's how much
you should spend um
it's kind of cool right because it says
it says mostly you should
i mean you should put a lot of money
into the third channel
um much less into the first
and a little bit into the second or
something like that i mean you can
however you want to describe uh that
vector but it tells you what to do
um so let's actually here's here's the
matrix and it's plotted this way let me
explain what it is
these are the groups and you can see
channel 1 channel 2 and channel
3 here and
let's just let's focus on channel two so
channel two says that for one dollar if
you spend on channel two here's what you
get
you're gonna get oh i don't know uh in
demographic group one you're gonna hit
like 1.9
that's 1.9 that's 1900 impressions um
oh we're doing really well on
demographic two so i don't know what
channel two
is right or demographic two but i tell
you this demographic the people
in demographic two are reading watching
or whatever or being exposed to
channel 2 clearly now you're doing
pretty badly out here
demographic 10. so every dollar you
spend on
channel 2 basically almost no one in
demographic group 10 is seeing it
okay so this is the idea so this shows
this will give you this this is actually
a pictorial picture of the matrix r
okay now when i actually spend
this amount here uh i will i get
remember my target
was a thousand so what i wanted was i
wanted every all ten of these to be
lined up at a thousand
well uh here's what happens there's a
drum roll
and it turns out this is what i achieved
by this spending vector
i get this and it's really pretty cool
right what i would
love is for all of these gray bars to be
right at a thousand
that mean i nailed it it would mean like
you know you go back to whoever it was
who gave
who gave you v desired and said i got a
spending plan and we nail it
that's it that'd be perfect right i mean
the whole thing is silly right because
you know who knows how many people
actually buy it that's another story
fine um but and here's what you can see
out of the 10
you know we come in a little bit low i
mean here's like 800 and something and
here we come up a little bit high it's
maybe uh 1200
right but you know pretty much all
around we're getting
you know we're between 800 and 1200 you
know
usually right and for some of them we're
really close like here you go
demographic 10 we pretty much nailed so
you know that's the idea
so this is just an example of
how you would use least squares in
practice and it's kind of clear that
it's a little bit obvious
now this one was silly because it's
three channels there's just three
three variables so you honestly could
have tuned it by hand but
let's remember that the exact same code
would work if there were
500 channels and 10 000 groups
okay so it would just work perfectly
let's suppose the groups were
broken up by region so if you said well
in the north bay 18 to 22 year olds you
know blah blah blah all this kind of
stuff
you could easily end up with 10 000
groups
and you could easily have hundreds and
hundreds of channels and the exact same
code
by the way the code is basically s
equals r backslash be desired i'll just
write the code out for you right here
it's it's s hat equals r
backslash v desired oh uh one thing i
should
i should be very clear about um r is not
the r from the qr factorization r is the
reach matrix that's why it's got the
name
r okay so in which case by the way if
there were 500
advertising channels and 10 000 groups
you could not do this by hand
i mean you might attempt to but it would
be really pretty stupid frankly because
you can just do it and get
a beautiful spending thing like that
okay
uh good so that's our first example
our second one um involves illumination
so what it is is i have a region that i
want to illuminate
and i have lights that are up uh up up
above us and they're in weird locations
it's not on a regular grid
so here's light number one is right here
and at lamp number one and it's four
meters above the floor
okay uh here's lamp number two and it's
3.5 meters above the floor
and here is lamp 10 and it's 4.5 meters
above the floor now
you can picture what happens right that
when you're
higher above the floor it means that
when you turn that light on it's going
to cast a wider pattern
of light it'll be it'll be weaker but
it'll be it'll it'll it'll actually cast
a wider
uh a pattern of illumination okay
and so there you go that's what it is so
aij
is going to be the illumination in
region i
so i divide up my ground into uh
regions here uh which is there's 625
regions because
it's it's a i make them like pixels of
25 by
25. so uh i have a
uh you know these are my so i have 625
uh pixels or or regions right
and the illumination in that i'm going
to have a be a matrix where aij is the
illumination in region i
if lamp j is on with power one and all
other lamps are off
okay so you go into this thing
and you do the following um you turn
lamp j on to power one everybody else
off so there's a single soul light
you know spreading light down and you'll
get a pattern and look you know what
it's gonna look like it's gonna be kind
of circular and it's gonna be brightest
right under the light and it's gonna
it's gonna tail off and stuff like that
i believe the data for this is done
using with a very simple standard
inverse square model so you know the
farther you are
from the light source the illumination
goes down like this you don't even need
to know that it's not relevant anyway
this is how you do it oh and you'll also
see that when i said this experiment of
heating up
lamp j to power one and turning all the
others off
you should by now be associating that
with
that's a unit vector that's what that is
and so
and that gives a column of a so let's
just talk about a for a minute
so a looks like this right
and a column of a actually gives you the
illumination
pattern of that particular lamp because
a column is associated with a lamp right
so
presumably the all the numbers are non
are positive right
presumably the largest number in here
occurs
at a pixel which is right under uh the
the lamp the the source
right um but other than that they're you
know they're all
some are big some are small if you're
very far away it's very small
now row is also super interesting a row
actually tells you is corresponds to a
pixel like that guy
right there and the row tells you
it tells you that for all the lamps
how much per watt do they illuminate you
okay and so in this case we would assume
that
these guys are close they're close but
they're also kind of high
right relatively high relatively
speaking so we would assume
that the entry in this row the fourth
entry and the eighth entry would be
pretty big so with the fifth entry by
the way
and maybe the ninth and probably the
smallest entry would be
the third entry in that row right so so
you can think of it this way a row
tells you the lighting efficiency
of all of your lamps for a particular
pixel
or region okay that's it
and i have uh if i multiply a by x
that means i add the power level you
know each at each lamp
uh is it is spraying light down and i
just add up the illumination levels and
ax gives me a vector a 625 vector in
this particular example
it's m is 625 and basically it says
that this is the illumination pattern
you get if you use power
x okay and then i have a target
illumination level of bi
right so maybe who knows i just have
some left some
target i would like it could just be
uniform that's simple right
but it doesn't have to be you could for
example say i want a lighting gradient
meaning i want it to to to very linearly
or
affinely across this uh across this
region
okay okay so here we are
uh what we're going to do is we are
going to attempt to achieve
uniform uh uniform illumination okay
now we've arranged everything that if
you just turn all the lamps to power one
that's that's x equals one this is the
illumination pattern
and red means brighter uh
blue means darker and if you do that you
get something like this
hardly surprising right what you see is
that this is very well illuminated
because
actually because they're in view of a
lot of lights and you turn them all on
to one
to one unit then you know it's going to
be over lit and then over here
like in the corner it's pretty dark it's
dark because
well there's not that many lights near
it uh so okay
and what we have here is this is the
histogram
so there's a total of 625
you know regions or pixels and this
tells you what the illumination is and
you can see they kind of center around
one that's cool this is our target right
we we want everything to be an
illumination of one
yeah but you can see uh i mean
presumably the blue here is uh that's
over there it's pretty
you know your illumination is down to
0.5 um some places have an illumination
that's up at like 1.6
and that's presumably the red places
okay so this is the picture
now we do least squares we just simply
do
backslash in code or we form the least
squares
one by the way the same comment i made
about the last example holds here
that is to say that when you solve this
problem it
you could end up with negative lamp
powers which by the way would give you
stunningly good lighting
i just there is no such thing you can't
do that but we'll skip that and pretend
it doesn't it did not happen in this
case
and what this does is it tells you
it tells you what to do with your lights
and it's actually pretty cool i don't
have that here
but what it says is this light should be
a little bit brighter
than one and these guys you really gotta
back off from one
right and the reason you back off from
them is because
they're in an area with a lot of lights
and they don't need to be that bright
okay so you're just sort of compensating
for all that i'm right now i'm
anthropomorphizing
how this works right so that's actually
going to be an important part in least
squares is going to be able to do all
sorts of crazy stuff and people would
say
how did you do that what happened or
something and then you can tell a story
and you sometimes it's better to say
well to pick up a story now the truth is
what you really do is you just did least
squares but okay
now when you do that visually you can
just see that that's a whole lot better
than the one above right and the one
above you see hot spot in the middle
and cooler spots here well you can't
avoid
some cool spots like this but the hot
spots are kind of gone
and sure enough look at this if that's
the if that's our target
you can see that you know actually
uh a whole a whole lot of that region is
is is within you know uh you know
between
0.85 and 1.15 so you went from
these things here where the errors were
you know easily
uh 25 down to one where they're like 10
that's pretty good
okay so again this is just an example
uh but it should give you start you
thinking about you know
applications of least squares of which
we will see
many many many many so good